[Musique]
donc atteint
ils ont à peine 16 ans et ne manque
jamais une occasion de rendre hommage
aux anciens combattants de 1945
ça me rappelle mon arrière grand père
qu'il faisait la guerre j'étais à berlin
la mémoire fait important pour chacun
il y a deux ans elisabetta et dimitri
ont rejoint yuna mia un mouvement
patriotique créé il ya six ans par le
ministère de la défense
au programme maniement des armes anti
cours d'histoire
préparation en cas d'attaqué chimique
marche au pas
c'est
[Musique]
une formation militaire que l'on peut
suivre dès 8 ans
[Musique]
je suis devenu plus mûr
plus disciplinés
je me suis fait beaucoup de copains à
moscou et ailleurs
je suis devenu plus solidaire ça me
manquait vraiment et puis plus
responsable aussi j'ai appris à
comprendre les autres
plus tard elle rêve de devenir pilote
dans l'armée de l'air lui veut devenir
pompier
enfants de policiers ou d'ingénieur ils
disent ne pas s'intéresser à l'actualité
quant à l'ukraine
honnêtement c'est quelque chose dont on
ne parle pas
on est au courant et ça suffit est ce
qu'on entend aux infos ça suffise
moi personnellement je ne m'y intéresse
pas j'en entends parler mais c'est tout
comme plus d'un million de petits
soldats ont rejoint les rangs de yuna
mia un engagement qui touche toutes les
générations
à 60 kilomètres de là dans la campagne
moscovite
alexandre saoul gorkin 61 non
collectionne les armes de la seconde
guerre mondiale
ça c'est le fusil automatique russe papa
ch a pris fin
ça nous a beaucoup aidés au front je
n'étais pas né à l'époque mais grâce à
ces armes c'est un peu comme si j'y
étais
chaque 9 mai ce chef d'entreprise
célèbre la victoire sur l'allemagne
nazie en costume et en famille
chaque citoyen doit se comporter en
patriote et transmettre cela de
génération en génération
c'est indispensable
ici on entretient le souvenir des
parents partis combattre ou soigner les
blessés
les enfants vous savez ça c'est votre
arrière grand mère elles étaient trois
copines elle était infirmière vous
médecin militaire
ça c'est mon grand père nicolas petrovic
il conduisait un camion lance roquettes
katioucha la traversée de cette route de
moscou à berlin ça a duré quatre ans
comment ne pas être fier de ça comment
mettre ça de côté et oubliés
comme de nombreux russes les sourds
gorkin s'inquiètent pour leurs proches
en ukraine
l'opération spéciale les a profondément
secoué
ça me fait de la peine pour les soldats
ukrainien mais aussi pour les autres je
ne veux pas qu'il y ait cette guerre
entre deux pays frères
on ne peut pas revenir en arrière c'est
trop tard mais ça me fait beaucoup de
peine
quand ces événements militaires ont
commencé j'ai pleuré pendant un mois
chaque jour je pleurais
sans adhérer à l'action de vladimir
poutine ni se mêler de politique
les soudeurs qui n'en restent pas moins
des patriotes amoureux d'une russie
vaillamment défendus par leurs aïeux